it was so fun and i i realized i like
that's so hard to find because
i you know if i were in college i feel
like it would be a little bit easier
but i'm going full full blown into music
so
um i miss it so much just
being able to have that many musicians
at your fingertips and just it's so
nice and how um um
when your relationship with your coaches
are they really like checking in every
day or is that just when they
see a tv see this is this is
nba i did have to sign one so that's i'm
worried about that
no don't worry i'm going up but work our
way around i want to so
i know like you don't know how bad it is
this is what we assume
you don't have to tell me what you
excuse yeah okay
just don't we assume we always assume
everything is done for the camera
right correct babe yeah we assume that
the only time that the coaches get in
contact with you is the time when the
cameras are on that there really is no
true interpersonal relationship where
they're like i'm gonna foster
i'm really gonna help this kid grow into
the artist well no
i will say this yeah i will say this
there are times when that
does happen okay
there are there are yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah i know
okay i know that you don't have to
confirm nor deny we're just telling you
yeah yeah
but there's no way they'll keep the
positive right in positivity yes yes yes
add in the positives okay but like um
you know
i know this is not happening you wake up
and blake shelton is texting you going
you ready today boy right you're like
nah
bro you know that that part of the
bridge i still don't have my falsetto
all right right right and blake's going
i'll be get it boy
yeah get some warm tea in your lungs
and [ __ ] get it or whatever inhale
that doesn't happen right he doesn't
text you he can't confirm or do nothing
okay all right here's another thing
right um
another thing yeah another thing is that
i feel like some coaches
are better than others like for me i
think that kelly clarkson although she
wasn't
on your year kelly clarkson i feel like
is a good coach i feel like she would
actually call her i think she called
i think she calls oh i can say this
miley cyrus
i feel like she does all over it all
over
every single person on her team was like
taken care of
she had emails sending back she really
was like why was janice freeman on your
season yes she was yeah she was
insane she passed away she did yeah just
recently
why did you bring that up i know i got
all
yes that i believe sad bumps on my body
um okay what other assumptions
we made janice freeman okay and cause
you're incredible not only incredible
one of our favorites um
just to win in my opinion don't make me
cry right now one hundred percent yeah
[ __ ] up if you're going based off of
talent alone yeah
yeah yeah but there's a whole backside
to her just as a person just hanging out
with her just
meeting her she is so freaking powerful
like
it's it's an energy it's not even just
like the way she like talks to it and
i'm not saying this
just to just to say it like for real
she's like you can ask
anybody that that knew her she was well
here's how i know
the reason how i know why she was
powerful and a nice person
is that because miley when jenna's
passed away